i'm sorry what's your name
scarface scotty's what they call me they
call you scarface yes
tell me about this car
um macarthur park
uh
um a dude i knew
we had some words back and forth
i called him a punk and a lame i turned
my back to him
he stabbed me in the face with a five
inch blade
i had 76 staples in my face my cheek was
hanging off like this losing a lot of
blood
um
i
was on west lake behind macarthur park
so i didn't walk through
the um
the uh
the train station directly to the cops i
didn't want them to see me where i came
from so they could check the cameras so
i walked all around the block
so they wouldn't be able to check
cameras because we don't tell
you know i mean we take care of it
ourselves
scary where'd you where'd you grow up
where you from originally i was born
here in california at cedars-sinai's
um when i was four i went to visit my
family in london
um
announced to you know unknown to me
my father was having a sexual
relationship with my mom's best friend
so we stayed there for the next 10 years
and tell me about your parents
um
my mom did as good as she can as good as
she could
but my father had [ __ ] her up real bad
you know
so um
i had to deal with my mom she had a few
nervous breakdowns
and we'd find her walking around london
following the yellow brick road what she
said these were the yellow lions in the
road all around london and london's a
huge [ __ ] city you know
i was very worried for my mom back then
how would you describe your childhood um
not the same as anyone else's
good and bad in some parts
i grew up a little fast
i did things that other children didn't
do i did drugs at an early age
um
i experienced a lot of things at an
early age
uh
i started doing graffiti in 1989.
um and that's when [ __ ] really got
[ __ ] crazy you know
um
i started doing graffiti in 1989 when i
came back
i met a friend of mine across the street
his name was roman
and they called him caper
and we started to go out we were from a
crew called 818k
and we started to go out and paint
billboards and [ __ ] on ventura and then
that progressed to painting freeway
science and that progressed to going all
city from
from san francisco to oregon and on and
you know so on and so on and until i
caught 11 million dollar charge
i caught in four days 11 million dollars
in damages
um through my graffiti and i was looking
at seven years upstate
at uh 17 years old
because of my graffiti
how'd they catch you
uh we got into a chase
we were seen by highway patrol
or no we were seen by caltrans and cal
trans
um
contacted highway patrol
uh
we
ran from miami patrol for a few hours
they eventually caught us in the support
pass in the
riverbed
because the helicopters were out we
couldn't get away so
that was the beginning of that
how much time did you actually do
uh initially um
just a week or so and then uh
and then um
i got out got caught again
and that's when they got really bad um
i did i believe nearly a year the county
for that
and i was looking at about seven to nine
years in uh prison
for my for my graffiti
how much prison time have you done total
um i just got out of prison last april i
just got off the four yard calipa
calipatria
i've done
probably five and a half six years
prison time
and drugs have been in your life for how
long a long time a long time drugs been
in my life uh
i started playing hockey
which i did too i started playing hockey
uh when i came back about about 13
and i was using a little bit of
marijuana stuff like that
i played hockey until i was
uh 23
i played uh six years in the triple-a
hockey league
and i actually got a
uh a
full ride i was picked up by montreal
and um
they gave me a
they gave me a um
contract that stated if i went to my
last summer or winter camp training and
um
they told me that if i gave them a year
in the farm team in montreal that did
guarantee me a year the nhl
and um i [ __ ] that up i didn't
i didn't go to my last winter camp
because i was very into my graffiti at
that time
i was being interviewed by
a couple magazines vice magazine
juxtaposed magazine
and i felt like i was being pressed into
something that i didn't know if i wanted
by my
you know by other people's expectations
of my family you know so
i [ __ ] that off and i regret that
but it was cool because i played for the
only california team to ever beat alaska
so that was cool
and today you're living right
i'm living downtown
everywhere you're just on the street i'm
on the streets
you're in a tent or you're just swinging
it no i've never been in a tent i'm
usually inside hotels
chicks houses you know stuff like that
day by day yeah day by day i make i make
it pretty i make i make
good money sometimes you know um
but
you know i'm also an addict so i also
have to feed that addiction so um
i uh
i spend a lot you know
and i do a lot of drugs and do a lot of
other people's [ __ ] and have friends
out here that need a lot of help so i
helped them what is your drug
dental
and you'll support yourself doing what
selling panel
and um
some uh
some small collections i do for a couple
bigger operators out here
so making collections
meaning just go talk to this person they
owe me a thousand bucks they'll be ten
thousand bucks i need to get paid
before this is going to escalate go talk
to them scotty i usually talk to them
once maybe twice
usually if i have to talk to them twice
they will pay that day but they usually
pay the first time i visit them
and the scar in your face probably helps
business
i don't care
you know
i i i do what i say i'm not scared i
don't give a [ __ ] about getting shot or
stabbed i've been shot four times
i've been stabbed three times and lost
my life twice
i have four of my best friends die in my
arms
my friend was murdered in my house
around my family by the cops
i woke up to my wife dead next to me
so i really don't give a [ __ ] about
anything
how old do you know
i'm 41. 41.
either married or in love
my wife died she died next to me in bed
how long ago was that
that was on november 20th 2017 so
sorry
and living down here
tell me about living on the street
starting kind of way
it's been harley it's been crazy this is
part of my life i'll never forget
it's a part of my life i think i may
have needed to have i needed i needed
this to see it
um i think a lot of people might need
this in their life
not saying that um
[Music]
i i need i need more of a lesson now but
uh
it does things to you if you if you
haven't been
if your life hasn't done you by yourself
this place will do it to you i'll never
forget what skid row has done to me
ever
i've seen
[ __ ] gnarly things
especially being a white boy
you know i have to really press the
issue because i don't [ __ ] around i'm
not gonna get punked or i'm not
disrespected by anyone i don't care what
the [ __ ] they do
you know what i mean
but um i i i
move around pretty well
i'm pretty respected by
all the races you know what i mean so i
can move between the races
um
for the white boys out here i pretty
much um
i
have the final say for for the white
guys out here on the streets
when it comes down to things being um
organized and uh decisions that we have
to make you know
how were you first introduced to hard
drugs
um
i had a friend his name was michael buha
he did graffiti with me he called him
beetle from yr yard rats
and uh
he um said dude have you ever smoked
heroin i said no
he says the [ __ ] did you come over and
try it so i did
and i was like i'm gonna go outside and
smoke a cigarette and it was the most
unbelievable euphorically beautiful
cigarette and time i've ever had i i
never thought anything like that
and i wanted more of it you know
it's been it's been a [ __ ] ever
since what are you worried about
what are you afraid of
i'm afraid uh for my children
i have three kids who are they
or my mother
you think there's a chance that you'll
you won't get off the streets
or the drugs
oh yeah i'm gonna get off the drugs they
they
right now as we speak they're really
really at their last legs with me
you know i have to use a lot to get
loaded
i like to be dangerous and uh
i uh
i don't
um
i don't like using it i'm not gonna load
so i do use large amounts you know and
uh
sometimes um i don't i don't owe d
though
but sometimes when we're using people od
i've watched so many people die that you
couldn't save
i've watched people if i can
say go hurry you know i can and i i i
run into people that have no i can't
they're trying to [ __ ] sell it to me
you know and i'm like
it's [ __ ] atrocious dude and people
have died that way you know a lot of
people have seen a lot of people die a
lot of death too
it's mostly fentanyl that's causing
these deaths too
yes and no
um
uh
these um
well the people that don't know what
they're doing they want to hide no
matter what and if that mall is there
it's not a drug that you won't try for
your first heart drugs and it's not
something it will kill you immediately
and uh it has killed me twice i've i've
gone
i've it's been over for me luckily i had
some people that cared about me and
brought me back you know
is this your lowest point in your life
right now
i don't know it's been not been a bad
day you know i'm here with you you know
it's not been a bad day some days are
good
your attitude about living down here
isn't isn't the bleep you know
i'll tell you the truth i miss it
sometimes when i'm not here
i don't know why
you know maybe it's the people maybe
it's the [ __ ] that goes on maybe some
freedom i don't know
the one thing that does bother me though
is i have children
and i miss them immensely
greatly deeply you know
my youngest is hard for me to deal with
though
he looked so much like his mother
and i i was madly in love with his
mother badly
and
and would do anything for her
anything i did
like i said i died on the operating
table
you know
so uh
i came back and
see you like
excuse me she was like yeah
she um she was something else she was
something special to me and i woke up to
her dad
i i don't think i was mad enough to see
her i couldn't see the big picture you
know
give any regrets any other
yeah
not being mad enough for
not being a man that she wanted and
decided to spend her life with
she was so much better than me
so much more beautiful to me she
graduated from juilliard second her
class
she was a ballerina
she accepted to the royal academy of
arts dance
she also played water polo for a single
and she was a suicide girl
for four years
and she loved tattoos and [ __ ] and like
like that but she was a very different
kind of girl she was a very
subdued
um very uh
very um
a girl is very demure you know she
didn't speak much she didn't
it's not the person she was she liked to
read and she liked
the quaint things in life and she loved
to dance to ballet
and uh
she could do it so well so it was beaut
i was so madly in love with her
i still am
i still asked ask her every night to
come to me
i still
pined for her
but
she's gone
[Music]
something absolutely
just losing her make it harder for you
to
deal with
the situation
yeah it does
i would think out here it'd be better
not to have a girlfriend you know
because of the atrocious hit that goes
on with these girls you know
their boyfriends don't give them hustles
but their boyfriends go to jail expect
them just to live out here well they get
sick
and they find out when some guy comes
along and says hey
do this this this and i'll give you this
and this and this
and finally they do it because they're
so sick and now they're empowered by it
so now they're [ __ ] and doing this
and doing that it's like dig and all
sorts of [ __ ] for dope
and you're crying to me why your
girlfriend's doing that
you should have taught her hustle you
were out boosting all day why didn't you
try to boost
luckily my girl
she wasn't like that she didn't she
would never sell her body she would
never do anything like that ever i never
let her
um she uh
was very good
she was very good at
anything she did or she was good at
and um
i missed her immensely she was my little
partner in crime
you know we did a lot of gnarly things
together
a lot of gnarly [ __ ] things a lot of
burglaries and [ __ ] you know
she was down for it
and she loved me
you know she was way too good for me
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
the last important thing i've learned in
my life
i've learned that life is finite
and [ __ ] it is not a bad thing to say
but i got children i learned
so i mean i'm just kind of selfish i
don't want to lie to anyone
um
i love my children you know
but if i could i'd kill myself if i
could go to the same place that she is
i'd kill myself to be with her
that's a [ __ ] up thing to say but i
loved her immensely
and
losing her and
and uh
the drugs that i do every day like i
[ __ ] i have like a i have like a 350
a day drug habit you know and i still
can't donate high
i don't get high now
i just maintaining some kind of [ __ ]
weird
kind of [ __ ]
uh soda [ __ ]
reality
that i'm keeping up with i don't even
know what day it is dude because i
haven't slept in like five days i don't
know if i'm coming or going i got
money in my pocket know where i came
from doing xanax too so just getting
real [ __ ] weird
um
the money that i made for the last three
days i lost it
and i'll switch i've lost five six
thousand dollars before you know doing
dumb [ __ ] and i had to make that money
back you know
i was doing actually i was doing really
really good at one point selling dope
i was making nearly
three thousand dollars a day making
selling though at the park and i was
just living the life of a [ __ ]
little [ __ ] rock star i guess but
not happy about it
i just don't i don't know what it is yet
that drives me to do this
i don't know what it is yet that
that makes me come back to this
um
if uh
if i were to
give anyone some
advice or whatever
is uh in a situation like this is really
good to know yourself and know what
you're about
if you do
it can help you a lot down here um
my wife
let me know what kind of man i was i
found out was that man i wasn't what i
was capable of doing
and i loved her for that
and then she left me
she died
and it's caused a lot of problems to be
very angry
i uh
i
lashed out and did some [ __ ] [ __ ]
up [ __ ] to people you know i didn't
deserve it
and um
tried to make some kind of amends and
or whatever you know
uh
it's really you know like um
you know ask me whatever
whatever you want to know i'll tell you
yeah it's more
um
[Music]
i uh recently
uh got shot
uh for the for the next the second time
i was a 44 magnum
went through my arm broke my bone
shot hit me here under my last rib
traveled up broke all my ribs
serrated my liver punched out my lung
um put me in a coma
for
uh nine days
and then i died coming out of the
oklahoma i died for nearly uh
four and a half minutes
and they brought me back so now i don't
know
how
but they did
is there something that attracts you to
this lifestyle
uh i wouldn't say attracts me to this
lifestyle
i'm not really one for the garbage and
the stink and the [ __ ] and all that but
like
like this kind of lifestyle like i'm not
really into the muck i kind of like nice
stuff
but as far as like the grind goes every
day and like the freedom you know and
the way i i i have to tell you i i miss
it and i do like it
and it bothers me saying that because i
have children that i need to get to
and i don't want them to hate me
but they don't they won't understand
this yet
all right scotty thank you so much for
sharing your story
yeah anything else you can tell yeah i'm
good thank you very much
you